this video is made possible by nordvpn
if you are online you really must be
using a vpn and that's where nordvpn
comes in
i know it's tempting not to bother and
hope for the best but really those
stories that you read about people
having their data stolen do
happen and you don't want to make it
easy for anyone to do that but
using a vpn offers more than just
security for example
nordvpn lets you access any of its
thousands of servers in different
countries all around the globe
so if you've hit the end of your netflix
clue simply try changing the location of
your server and get access to content
libraries that due to licensing
agreements
are only available in specific
geographic locations for example
most european countries have strong
licensing agreements with restricting
which soccer matches can be viewed
depending on the location of the viewer
with nordvpn you can change your country
without even moving from your sofa
nordvpn is super fast so watching video
is a breeze
no lag whatsoever if you've ever used
vpns and thought they were slow
well no more with nordvpn and you can
use it on all your devices
very very easily android chrome windows
linux and on up to six different devices
one account also there are no logs kept
at all
unlike companies based in the eu or the
us nordvpn is based in panama so they
don't have to keep
logs at all great for your privacy so
take control of your internet experience
right now with nordvpn go to nordvpn.com
forward slash visualpolitik and use code
visualpolitik to get a two-year plan
plus one additional month with a
huge discount it's risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee
[Applause]
[Music]
dear friends in a past video here on
visualpolitik and together with our
friends
at value school we told you how the
administration of the now ex-president
of the united states of america donald
trump was making huge efforts to limit
the weight and integration of
china into world finance or at least to
curb its growing ties to the north
american markets
[Music]
however despite the insistent messages
of a possible decoupling and all the
attempts of the previous u.s
administration if 2020 has shown us
anything it is that the integration of
the asian giant into the world's
financial markets
is advancing at full speed
[Music]
money is starting to pour into china
because they're looking for that income
it's a really interesting point in
history the chinese have opened up and
you have the rest of the world in
serious trouble hayden briscoe head of
fixed income for
asia pacific at ubs asset management
[Music]
despite the sars coronavirus ii pandemic
the political confrontation with the
united states and events as tense as
those witnesses in hong kong
foreign investors bought more than 150
billion dollars worth of bonds and
shares in the chinese mainland markets
last year
[Music]
this makes it a new historical record
in total foreign ownership of chinese
stocks and bonds traded on these
continental markets
is already close to one trillion dollars
eight times more than just
six years ago we are talking about a
flow of investment that has accelerated
since the victory of democratic
candidate joe biden in the u.s
elections on 3rd of november and that
trend contributes to the fact that the
csi 300 index
china's reference index will have its
2020 figures revalued in dollars with a
increase putting it more than 13 points
above the s p
something that has allowed it to beat
its historical highs of 2015.
[Music]
chai next the technology division of the
shenzhen stock exchange
also managed to beat the north american
nasdaq composite with a 59
appreciation measured in dollars
[Music]
yes you see during 2020 the chinese
markets were real stars
on the world financial scene however all
of this has only just a gun with more
than 1.4 billion consumers
a middle class of more than 600 million
people ever increasing purchasing power
a
huge production structure that is not
fully understood and an economy that
seems capable of resisting even the
attack of the coronavirus the appetite
of international investors for chinese
assets
is growing
and it's not just about the investors
the international industry giants also
want to take advantage of a market that
is simply gigantic
ray dalio himself founder and chairman
of bridgewater associates the world's
largest hedge fund predicted in a recent
interview with the financial times that
the markets in mainland china will soon
be tough
rivals for new york and london in the
race for the top spot among the world's
financial centers
china already has the world's second
largest capital markets and i think they
will eventually vie for having the
world's financial center throughout
history the largest trading countries
evolved into having the global financial
center and the global reserve currency
ray dalio
in the same interview he also said that
he expects that over time
china will represent a very important
part of bridgewater's own business
a hedge fund with some 150 billion
dollars under management now we are
talking about a very extraordinary
country as we will see later
and i'm sure this won't surprise anyone
investing in china has its risks
starting with the more than obvious
political and regulatory risks
so some of the questions we can ask
ourselves are why does china seem to be
generating so much expectation
in financial circles lately what
magnitudes are we talking about
how are things evolving will we really
see china become a major player in the
international financial scene well
let's answer all of these questions
a very coveted treasure
china is a giant and therefore
everything to do with it
almost always has enormous proportions
look at the bond market for example it
is still of course much smaller than the
u.s market but since the end of 2018 it
has been the second largest market in
the world
we're talking about almost 17 trillion
dollars
[Music]
these days the chinese market offers
higher rates at the same time thanks to
the good progress of exports and the
economy along with the growing entry of
capital flows
this market is feeding a tremendously
positive evolution of the yuan
4th of january 2021 renminbi rallies
past 6.5 per dollar for the first time
since 2018
chinese currency boosted by china's
economic recovery from covet 19 after
authorities successfully controlled the
virus
financial times
[Music]
and friends we are talking about a
situation which taking into account
the policies of central banks like the
fed or the european central bank and the
apparent strength of the chinese economy
suggests that it may last for quite some
time
[Music]
and exactly the same is true of the
stock market which also ranks china as
the second largest country in the world
in terms of value of listed companies
almost 11 trillion dollars
[Music]
of course unlike the north american
markets and those of any other developed
country the case of china stands out for
the reduced participation of foreign
investors for example foreigners
currently hold on to less than five
percent of china's outstanding shares
far below the figure of more than 30 in
markets such as japan
and south korea
but you see that is now starting to
change let's be clear the chinese
markets are simply too big and too
tempting to be ignored especially when
china has been one of the few economies
with
positive growth in 2020 and whose
forecasts for the following years are
also pretty promising too
[Music]
in addition as the role of the chinese
economy grows companies that make stock
indexes such as the msci or the ftse
russell are increasing the weighting of
chinese assets in these indexes which in
turn
forces passive investment funds to
increase their exposure to the chinese
[Music]
market
these are perhaps the two most
influential factors in the foreign
appetite for chinese assets but of
course
no matter how much appetite you have if
the market is closed it is not possible
to break through however
that is also changing floodgates open
the chinese government wants to increase
the country's integration into the
world's financial fabric
it wants to do so in order to increase
its access to world capital attract more
investors as well as to strengthen
its companies its currency and the
competitive position
as ray dalio said in the financial times
interview we mentioned earlier history
seems to show that an economic
powerhouse has to be a financial
powerhouse
as well well that is exactly what the
chinese government is doing
opening its doors and facilitating
access for investors and large
international financial groups
for example in 2019 chinese regulators
cleared the way for the full acquisition
of local banks by foreign groups
and from 2020 it has begun to allow for
foreign ownership of financial
enterprises of all kinds
insurance futures means of payment asset
management and so on
and that my friends has been a very
important step because you see
in the past foreign financial firms had
to resign themselves to operating at
best through minority stakes in joint
ventures with local partners
that is in most cases the chinese
partner had the final control over the
company
and now that's changed and has caused
many to be rubbing their hands together
to give you an idea of what we're
talking about the chinese financial
services
industry is worth about 50 trillion
dollars trillion with a big fat capital
t
currently only two percent of this
enormous market is in foreign hands
thus bloomberg recently estimated that
banks and foreign investment firms if
they improve their position could make
an additional annual profit of more than
9 billion
solely from their operations in china by
the end of this decade
the best example is the large american
groups since 2019
companies such as paypal goldman sachs
jp morgan american express blackrock
citibank and the rating agencies have
been launching significant operations in
this country after receiving the
approval of the chinese authorities
but it's not just the operations of
large groups the chinese government is
removing many restrictions to gradually
facilitate the purchase of stocks bombs
and derivatives by investors all around
the world
of course there is still a lot of work
to be done the point is
that all these changes promise to
further increase china's
interconnectedness
in global financial markets
there are many risks such as regulatory
risks in a country where legal security
is not exactly strong
there's also the political risk derived
from the tense confrontation between
beijing and washington
and the financial risk of a possible
future debt crisis that the well-known
manager of hedge funds
jim chanos has called a treadmill to
hell
but friends we will talk more about all
of this in future videos here on
visualpolitik with our friends from
value school the question
now is is ray dalio's prediction right
and will investors around the world
look at shanghai or shinzen as much as
they now look at wall street in a few
years time leave your answers down in
the comments below so
i really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
and as always i'll see you in the next
video and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear even more of my
lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there